SEPARATE EVACUATION CORRIDOR FOR
PEOPLE TRAPPED IN THE BROADER
CITY OUTSIDE THE PLANT, FOR
TOMORROW.
>> THANK YOU SCOTT VERY MUCH.
NOW, I WANT TO SHOW YOU MORE OF
MY CONVERSATION WITH THE
UKRAINIAN COMMANDER INSIDE THE
STEEL PLANT.
I BEGAN BY ASKING HIM TO TELL
ALL OF US WHAT IS HAPPENING
THERE TODAY.
>> Translator: TODAY, DURING THE
DAY, THE ENEMY WHAT IS BEEN
TRYING TO STORM ASOVSTAL.
SEVERAL UNITS HAVE ALREADY
ENTERED THE TERRITORY OF THE
PLANT, SO THERE HAS BEEN FIERCE
FIGHTING ON THE TERRITORY OF THE
PLANT TODAY.
>> THERE THERE -- PUTIN
OBVIOUSLY HAS SAID THAT HIS
ORDER TO RUSSIAN TROOPS TO AVOID
GOING INTO THE PLANT IS STILL IN
PLACE.
IT'S CLEAR FROM WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING THAT IS NOT TRUE.
ARE THERE TROOPS INSIDE THE
PLANT NEAR WHERE YOU ARE NOW?
WHAT DO YOU KNOW ABOUT THEIR
LOCATION?
>> Translator: WELL WE CAN SEE
THAT OBVIOUSLY, HIS WORDS ARE
NOT TRUE.
THIS IS ANOTHER LIE.
THE STORM OF THE PLANT IS GOING
ON.
SEVERAL UNITS HAVE ALREADY
MANAGED TO COME THROUGH TO THE
TERRITORY OF THE PLANT,
SUPPORTED BY THE TANKS, AVIATION
AND ALSO SHIPS FROM THE SEA.
SO OUR GUYS ARE CARRYING OUT THE
FIGHTING.
ALREADY, ON THE TERRITORY OF THE
PLANT.
>> HOW MUCH LONGER CAN YOU
CONTINUE FIGHTING, COMMANDER?
>> I CAN'T TELL YOU THE EXACT
NUMBER OF HOURS, DAYS OR MONTHS,
HOW LONG WE WILL BE ABLE TO
CARRY ON THE RESISTANCE, BUT I
CAN DEFINITELY TELL YOU THAT WE
WILL BE RESISTING UNTIL THE VERY
END.
>> COMMANDER, WHEN YOU SAY
RESISTING UNTIL THE VERY END, IT
IS HARD FOR ANYONE WATCHING TO
TRULY UNDERSTAND THE COURAGE AND
BRAVERY OF YOU AND YOUR PEERS IN
THERE FIGHTING.
DO YOU THINK THAT YOU WILL BE
ABLE TO COME OUT OF THAT PLANT
TO RETURN TO YOUR LIFE AND
FAMILY?
>> Translator: YOU ARE VERY
RIGHT WHEN YOU SAY THAT WE ARE
THINKING ABOUT OURSELVES IN THE
VERY LAST TERM BECAUSE WE WOULD
VERY MUCH WANT OUR REMAINING
CIVILIANS TO BE EVACUATED BE
FROM THE PLANT AS WELL AS OUR
WOUNDED SOLDIERS AND -- SO WITH
REGARD TO OURSELVES, OF COURSE
WE WOULD LIKE TO RETURN TO OUR
NORMAL LIFE, BUT THIS IS NOT OUR
FIRST PRIORITY.
>> COMMANDER, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>>> THE OTHER BREAKING NEWS AT
THIS HOUR, CNN LEARNING U.S.
INTELLIGENCE HELPED UKRAINIANS
TARGET AND SINK PUTIN'S PRIZED
WARSHIP, THE MOSKAVA, NATASHA,
WHAT MORE CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT
THE U.S.'S ROLE, THIS WAS
OBVIOUSLY A CRUCIAL MOMENT IN
THE WAR WHEN UKRAINE
SUCCESSFULLY SANK THAT PRIZED
JEWEL IN THE RUSSIAN FLEET.
>> Reporter: YEAH, ERIN, A HUGE
BLOW TO THE RUSSIAN MILITARY
THAT WAS.
IT WAS SEEN AS A MAJOR UKRAINIAN
VICTORY AND WHAT WE'RE LEARNING
NOW IS THAT THE U.S. ACTUALLY
PROVIDED TARGETING INTELLIGENCE
TO THE UKRAINIANS WITH REGARD TO
THE LOCATION OF THAT WARSHIP.
WHAT HAPPENED IS THE UKRAINIAN
FORCES ACTUALLY SAW THAT WARSHIP
IN THE BLACK SEA AND THEY WERE
WONDERING WHETHER THAT WAS THE
MOSKAVA SO CALLED FOR THAT
CONFIRMATION NOT TO WASTE THE
CRUISE MISSILES NOW THE U.S. DID
PROVIDE THEM WITH THE EXACT
LOCATION OF THAT SHIP AND DID
CONFIRM IT WAS THE MOSKAVA BUT
IT WAS EMPHASIZED TO US THE
UNITED STATES DID NOT KNOW THE
UKRAINES WERE GOING TO TARGET
THE SHIP ITSELF WITH THEIR OWN
MISSILES.
U.S. HAS BEEN PROVIDING UKRAINE
WITH MARITIME INTELLIGENCE TO
GIVE THEM A GENERAL SENSE OF
AWARENESS ABOUT THE KIND OF
ACTIVITY GOING ON IN THE BLACK
SEA BECAUSE OF COURSE THOSE
RUSSIAN SHIPS HAVE BEEN FIRING
MISSILES ON TO UKRAINIAN
TERRITORY SO IT WAS EMPHASIZED
TO US THERE WAS NO U.S. ROLE IN
THE DECISION MADE TO TARGET THE
SHIP.
HOWEVER, IT REMAINS TO BE SEEN
OF COURSE WHETHER RUSSIA IS
GOING TO APPRECIATE THAT
DISTINCTION, RIGHT, BECAUSE OF
COURSE THEY HAVE THREATENED THAT
ANY U.S. AND NATO ROLE IN THIS
WAR AS IT GROWS COULD BE
SUSCEPTIBLE TO A RUSSIAN ATTACK.
>> ALL RIGHT, NATASHA, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, OBVIOUSLY SOBERING
AND THIS COMES ON THE HEELS OF
LEARNING THAT U.S. INTELLIGENCE,
THE NEW YORK TIMES REPORTING WAS
USED IN THE TARGETING OF RUSSIAN
GENERALS.
I WANT TO BRING IN JAMES CLAPPER
BECAUSE HE IS FORMER DIRECTOR OF
NATIONAL INTELLIGENCE UNDER
PRESIDENT OBAMA AND ALSO RETIRED
LIEUTENANT GENERAL IN U.S. AIR
FORCE.
SO GENERAL, WHEN YOU HEAR THIS
THAT U.S. INTELLIGENCE WAS USED,
OBVIOUSLY THE SOURCES TELLING
NATASHA OH BUT WE DIDN'T KNOW,
WELL WE CONFIRMED ITS LOCATION
AND WHAT IT WAS THAT THEY WERE
ACTUALLY GOING TO USE THAT TO
STRIKE.
OKAY.
DO YOU BUY THAT?
I MEAN IT IS A PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT PIECE OF REPORTING
TO FIND THAT THIS SHIP WAS
BROUGHT DOWN IN PART BECAUSE OF
U.S. INFORMATION.
>> LAUREN, WHEN YOU SHARE
INTELLIGENCE WITH A PARTNER,
PARTICULARLY ONE THAT IS
INVOLVED IN COMBAT, FOR ITS
NATURAL SURVIVAL AND YOU'RE
SHARING INTELLIGENCE WITH THEM,
YOU HAVE TO ASSUME THEY'RE GOING
TO USE IT TO THE MAXIMUM BENEFIT
FOR THEM AND THAT CARRIES WITH
IT, BY THE WAY, THE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR U.S.
INTELLIGENCE TO ENSURE WHAT IS
PROVIDED TO UKRAINIANS IS
ACCURATE.
I'VE HEARD COMPLAINTS FROM SOME
PEOPLE THAT WE'RE NOT PROVIDING
INTELLIGENCE RAPIDLY ENOUGH.
WELL, IT'S UP -- RESPONSIBILITY
IS ON US TO ENSURE THAT THE
INTELLIGENCE THAT WE ARE
PROVIDING IS ACCURATE AS WELL AS
TIMELY, BUT ONCE YOU SHARE THAT
INTELLIGENCE, WITH A PARTNER,
PARTICULARLY ONE WHO IS GOING TO
USE IT TO KILL PEOPLE AND
DESTROY THINGS, THAT'S PART OF
THE DEAL.
>> SO LOOK, THE ADMINISTRATION
UNDERSTANDS THAT THIS IS A REAL
LOADED THING, BECAUSE THEY ARE
PUSHING BACK, WHITE HOUSE IS
PUSHING BACK ON THE TIMES REPORT
THAT INTEL THE UNITED STATES IS
SHARING WITH UKRAINE IS HELPING
THEM KILL RUSSIAN GENERALS AND
WE KNOW AN UNPRECEDENTED AMOUNT
OF RUSSIAN GENERALS KILLED.
THE WHITE HOUSE SAYS THAT NEW
YORK TIMES REPORT IS MISLEADING
AND IRRESPONSIBLE.
THEY SAY, QUOTE, WE DO NOT
PROVIDE INTELLIGENCE WITH THE
INTENT TO KILL RUSSIAN GENERALS.
AGAIN, 12 RUSSIAN GENERALS
UKRAINE SAYS THEY HAVE KILLED
BUT AGAIN, WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF
THAT DENIAL?
THAT'S NOT TO SAY THEY ARE NOT
PROVIDING INTELLIGENCE ABOUT THE
RUSSIAN GENERALS.
>> AS I SAID, THE INTENT MAY NOT
HAVE BEEN SPECIFICALLY TO SHARE
INTELLIGENCE WITH UKRAINIANS TO
KILL RUSSIAN GENERALS, BUT IF
YOU SHARE INTELLIGENCE THAT
GIVES THE UKRAINIANS SITUATIONAL
AWARENESS, IF YOU HELP EITHER
IDENTIFY OR REINFORCE, FOR
EXAMPLE, WHERE A HEADQUARTERS
IS, RUSSIAN HEADQUARTERS, WELL
THAT'S WHERE GENERALS GENERALLY
GRAVITATE IS THE HEAD QUARTER.
SO ONCE AGAIN, ONCE YOU MAKE THE
DETERMINATION, THE POLICY
DETERMINATION, YOU'RE GOING TO
SHARE INTELLIGENCE WITH A
PARTNER PARTICULARLY ONE
INVOLVED IN COMBAT THEN YOU'RE
GOING TO USE IT TO THE BEST OF
THEIR ABILITY AND MAXIMUM EXTENT
POSSIBLE.
>> SO GENERAL, THIS INFORMATION
IS NOW PUBLIC IN TERMS OF HOW
THE INTELLIGENCE IS BEING
SHARED.
DO YOU THINK IT WILL HAVE AN
IMPACT ON THE WAR?
>> WELL AS SOMEBODY WHO SPENT,
YOU KNOW, A LIFETIME IN
INTELLIGENCE, ALMOST GIVES ME
HIVES WHEN THESE THINGS ARE
PUBLICLY REVEALED.
SO THE EFFECT COULD BE, ALTHOUGH
IT HASN'T BEEN SO FAR, THAT THE
RUSSIANS COULD TIGHTEN UP THEIR
OPERATIONAL SECURITY WHICH HAS
BEEN ABSOLUTELY DISMAL AND
ACCORDINGLY, THE INTELLIGENCE,
PERHAPS, MIGHT DRY UP.
THERE'S ALWAYS THE CONCERN OF
THE PROTECTION OF SOURCES AND
METHODS.
SO TO THAT EXTENT, I SUPPOSE IT
COULD AFFECT THE WAR BUT I